(steady pensive piano music)
- [Voiceover] One of the
coolest things is when we take
a diver with a disability in open water.
The word freedom comes up
over and over and over again
because that's how they
describe their feeling.
(steady pensive piano music)
My name's Jim Elliott, founder
and president of Diveheart.
We help people with disabilities
using zero gravity and scuba therapy.
It's a great equalizer.
We take their new normal, in some cases,
and we help create a paradigm shift
so now the individual with the disability
isn't defined by that disability.
And they go into a room, and people say:
"You do what?
"You scuba dive?
"That's impossible!
You're in a wheelchair."
- [Jim] Tilt it back a little bit?
OK, guys, come up.
- I was on my bicycle,
and I was struck by a car,
and I hurt my T11 vertebrae
and severed my spinal cord.
I knew that all of a sudden
when I lost the feeling
and the ability to move my
legs that life had changed.
- When I was 23 years
old, I dove into a pool
and I dislocated my C67 vertebrae,
which led me to be
paralyzed from my neck down.
I'm totally dependent from
someone else all the time.
I suffer from neurological pain,
and I take medication for that,
but every time I get into
the water I feel better;
I don't feel pain for a
couple of days, so I love it.
- We see immediate pain relief.
Individuals with everything
from MS to spinal-cord injuries
and cerebral palsy can become pain-free.
If we can get divers deep enough,
to 66 feet, which is three atmospheres,
there's an extra output of
serotonin in the human body.
The serotonin will help
with the pain management
up to three weeks.
It just helps their quality of life
in so many different ways:
body, mind and spirit.
- Diving is just amazing,
'cause I get outta this position
and I can kinda do whatever I want
and get in whatever position I want,
which you don't get to do on land.
When you're kinda stuck to a chair,
being weightless is one
of the best feelings.
- I was looking at myself standing up;
and that was, for me, fabulous.
I loved it.
I was like: "Oh my god,
"I cannot believe I'm seeing
myself standing up again!"
After, imagine, so many years,
15 years that I got my accident.
I feel like totally independent
and I feel like freedom,
liberty out of the power chair.
It's me again.